Julie Stout: I think we are recording. So, hello, my name is Julie Stout, I'm here with John Hasse. I'm currently located in Bloomington, Indiana, and John, can you let me know where you're located again?
John Hasse: Alexandria, Virginia.
Julie Stout: Nice. Today is March 13th, 2026, and I'm excited to be here with John to ask about his life and tell us his life story. And if you're ready to go, I can dive right in.
John Hasse: Please do.
Julie Stout: Awesome. Okay.
Julie Stout: So, my first question is a simple one, please give me your full name and pronunciation.
John Hasse: John Edward Hassey.
Julie Stout: And how old are you today, and what is your date of birth?
John Hasse: I was born November 28th, No, sorry, it's my daughter's birthday.
John Hasse: November 20th, 1948, and I'm 77.
Julie Stout: Nice, okay.
Julie Stout: And could you tell me a little bit about your family life and childhood? Like, your parents and your guardians and their occupations? Do you have siblings? What would you want to speak about for that?
John Hasse: My parents, were… both teachers.
John Hasse: They met at college, Carlton College in Minnesota.
John Hasse: Which is also my alma mater.
John Hasse: I was born in Aberdeen, South Dakota.
John Hasse: And when I was about 6 or 7,
John Hasse: My fam- my father got a job.
John Hasse: He had been teaching high school, he got a job.
John Hasse: at the University of South Dakota, teaching math and astronomy, so we moved there, and so I became a faculty brat.
John Hasse: And graduated high school there, and then…
John Hasse: I left the state. I have, I had.
John Hasse: Five siblings, my two… Oldest sisters have passed away.
John Hasse: My brother is 92, still alive.
John Hasse: And I have a younger sister.
John Hasse: Margaret, who's a… A well-known poet lives in the Twin Cities of Minnesota.
Julie Stout: What's your relationship like with your family? Are you close with your parents, or were you close with your parents? Or your siblings?
John Hasse: I was. I was. Very close with my mother. My father was,
John Hasse: Very smart man, and very dedicated to teaching.
John Hasse: He could be, he had a bad temper, and that, cause some distance sometimes.
John Hasse: But he died the week I graduated from college.
John Hasse: He fought, cancer for 5 years and passed away.
John Hasse: just before… days before I graduated from his.
John Hasse: alma mater.
John Hasse: My mother, lived 5 more years, but 3 of those were with leukemia, so…
John Hasse: By the time I was… well, let's see…
John Hasse: 27, I was, you could say an orphan, no parent, so… It's been…
John Hasse: 50 years since they've been gone, and I miss them a lot.
Julie Stout: Yeah, I definitely understand that. It's not ever easy to lose a loved one at all.
Julie Stout: Do you have any memories that come to mind in terms of, like, fond childhood memories, or, experiences with your family, or something that just comes to mind for you?
Julie Stout: Oh, many.
John Hasse: Go on a long time, but, my parents were very supportive.
John Hasse: And, we didn't have a lot of money, but they…
John Hasse: got me piano lessons starting when I was in second grade.
John Hasse: Turk classical piano.
John Hasse: throughout high school and college, but by the time I was a teenager, I'd gotten interested in
John Hasse: vernacular music, especially jazz.
John Hasse: Started a jazz trio in high school. It's also in a rock slash soul slash blues band.
John Hasse: As a high schooler, and…
John Hasse: The jazz experience was very formative when I got to Carlton, I…
John Hasse: learned everything I could about jazz, and spent a…
John Hasse: 6 months in New York City, Studying with two top…
John Hasse: jazz pianist, African-American jazz pianist, and…
John Hasse: Ended up majoring in Black Studies to put my interest in black music into historical and cultural context.
Julie Stout: What do you think, like, speaks to you about music? What drives you to music? And to do it, to learn about it, and to study it?
John Hasse: Oh, it speaks to me on many levels. Emotional… The values it expresses…
John Hasse: In turn, in jazz, it's the rhythm and syncopation and the fact that
John Hasse: Every jazz performance is supposed to be different.
John Hasse: the previous performance, fresh because of improvisation. And I like the challenge of playing jazz, because
John Hasse: You always have to keep it fresh. You can never play the same thing twice.
John Hasse: And, every day of my life, I've listened to classical music.
John Hasse: I deeply love that.
John Hasse: But I, I, I have,
John Hasse: special admiration for jazz because of…
John Hasse: A really good jazz musician has to be able to do everything
John Hasse: A really good classical music institution does, but also compose at the speed of thought.
John Hasse: To improvise, and that takes… Great, great skill.
Julie Stout: Do you think that came to you naturally, or did you… when you did that training with the two people in New York, I think you said?
Julie Stout: Did they, like, help you along to learn how to do that and improvise and everything, or what would you say?
John Hasse: Yes, my mother said that Before I could… walk, I'd stand in the… Crib, holding onto the railing.
John Hasse: And sway back and forth to music on the radio.
John Hasse: And, so I think I had music in me from… from birth.
John Hasse: Both my parents had studied music when they were youngsters,
John Hasse: My father studied violin. He said the dog used to howl along when he played.
John Hasse: And, my mother also studied a stringed instrument, so… There was some… Music in our backgrounds.
Julie Stout: Did your siblings do it, too? Did you ever play with your siblings?
John Hasse: No, but I'd fall asleep…
John Hasse: There's a 10 years gap between me and the next oldest.
John Hasse: And so, I would fall asleep listening to my older sisters play Mozart.
John Hasse: And… Let's see, by the time I was in…
John Hasse: grade school, they had all moved on and were either in college or they'd gotten married by then.
John Hasse: So we didn't… we didn't play together, but they… I'm sure they encouraged me. And my younger sister, who's very talented.
John Hasse: artistically,
John Hasse: doesn't have a very musical ear, I don't think she could carry a tune in a bucket, but…
John Hasse: I don't hold that against her, because she's a wonderful wordsmith.
John Hasse: published, I think, 8 books of poetry.
Julie Stout: So you definitely have, like, creative arts that have run through your family that you think influence you to who you are today?
John Hasse: Oh, yes, my oldest sister, now deceased, Trudy, was a very fine… Painter.
John Hasse: And… My sister, Ellen, who is still with us, He's 10 years older.
John Hasse: Majored in… drama, radio, and television at the University of South Dakota, and she was in plays, even
John Hasse: When she was in high school, and I was influenced by her.
John Hasse: Dramatic in public speaking skills.
John Hasse: And my sister Ann, who… We lost last October.
John Hasse: lived… Her life.
John Hasse: as an artist. She was artistic.
John Hasse: Just about every way, and so… My mother was a, very fine amateur poet.
John Hasse: Published in a number of different, literary magazines.
John Hasse: And, so I'm sure that the… I was influenced by the…
John Hasse: Amount of arts in my upbringing.
Julie Stout: I think it's really inspiring, too, the fact that not everyone did music per se, but they still found a way to, like, express themselves in some way as well, which is really awesome.
Julie Stout: I want… you mentioned that you were in a band in high school? Like, you had, like, a trio?
Julie Stout: Or something like that? Do you… did you stay in touch with any of the people that you played with in that capacity?
Julie Stout: For some years, yes, it was called the…
John Hasse: JB3, because… There were two Johns and a Bob.
John Hasse: In this piano, bass, drums trio.
John Hasse: And then I joined… Of the group of, college graduates.
John Hasse: In a… electric band called the Five Line Transport Blues Band.
John Hasse: And the band was doing,
John Hasse: Well, we had to do things like Louis Luis, because the dancers wanted it.
John Hasse: And, some… Unusual songs by the Mothers of Invention.
John Hasse: And such bands.
John Hasse: And some Southside Chicago Blues by Willie Dixon and Muddy Waters and people like that.
John Hasse: probably the only band in South Dakota In 1966.
John Hasse: that was doing Southside Chicago Blues.
Julie Stout: And, did you… were you able to, like, did you tour informally, or where would you, like, perform… where were you performing?
John Hasse: Well, the trio played, fraternity and sorority dances.
John Hasse: nightclubs, places like that, and the…
John Hasse: The Rock Soul Blues Bland played at, dance halls, and also fraternity dances as well.
John Hasse: And then when I got to Carleton, I started a, a trio…
John Hasse: piano, bass, and drums, and we called it Maiden Voyage, named after one of Herbie Hancock's…
John Hasse: Latest, and, influential albums.
John Hasse: Maiden voyage.
Julie Stout: And that continued through your entire time in college, or were you able to continue it after college, or…
John Hasse: when I graduated, it came to a close. I played for.
Julie Stout: a while ago.
John Hasse: in Minneapolis after that. I was in a polka band for a while.
John Hasse: But when I came to Washington, No, wait.
John Hasse: I'm jumping ahead. I graduate in 71.
John Hasse: I moved to IU, Bloomington, 73.
John Hasse: Got my master's… in… Ethnomes, ecology, and Folklore in 75.
John Hasse: Worked on a dissertation, and… I got a research grant.
John Hasse: And… graduated 81.
John Hasse: moved, and during that time, I was giving one man, mostly plain, One-man concerts of ragtime.
John Hasse: Jazz.
John Hasse: And blues, boogie Woogie.
John Hasse: But, I joined a… a…
John Hasse: Group, there were four of us.
John Hasse: We called ourselves the New Hoosier Hotshots.
John Hasse: We had a bass, no, a tuba player, trombonist, banjoist, And myself on piano.
John Hasse: Then I got a job playing the piano in Nashville, Indiana.
John Hasse: at a colonial-themed tavern called The Ordinary.
John Hasse: And I played there for 6 years, every weekend.
John Hasse: 600 nights, they helped me… it helped me work my way through graduate school.
John Hasse: Most of the time, I was just… just me at the piano, but… The, restaurant
John Hasse: Team me up with a banjo player who also sang, so for a while there was two of us.
John Hasse: And then… When I got to, cincinnati, In 1981, I was hired by Procter & Gamble.
John Hasse: in marketing management, I couldn't find a teaching job.
John Hasse: And I went to, to crash business training at the Wharton School at the University of Pennsylvania.
John Hasse: and was hired by Procter & Gamble in Marketing Management.
John Hasse: And that didn't work out after 13 months. They actually had me leave the company.
John Hasse: And, so for a couple years, I scuffled. I got a research grant, and I was also playing piano.
John Hasse: in a piano bar in Cincinnati.
John Hasse: To make a long story short.
John Hasse: When I arrived in Washington in 1984,
John Hasse: A dear friend of mine said, John, you don't want to be… The person, the musician.
John Hasse: Coming in the back door or the side door.
John Hasse: You don't want to be that person at events. You want to be one of the people coming in the front door.
John Hasse: And I thought, That was more becoming of a… Smithsonian curator, so…
John Hasse: I followed that advice, and after that.
John Hasse: If I played in public, it was part of a… Lecture concert.
Julie Stout: that was a lot of changes in that time period! And,
Julie Stout: just so I'm a bit more, like, clear about, like, your timeline of things, can you go over your, like, education again, in, like, the years and institutions? And then, also, if you can touch on people that inspired you, your mentors, your advisors, whoever helped you through as well, that'd be, great to hear about.
John Hasse: Sure.
John Hasse: Well, like… Let's see, graduated Carleton in 1971.
John Hasse: Worked in the Twin Cities in a presidential campaign.
John Hasse: for 2 years, and after the campaign ended, I had a series of odd jobs.
John Hasse: Went on the road with a rock.
John Hasse: slash show band.
John Hasse: I worked in a paint factory for a week.
John Hasse: Of her big fats of… of, poisonous fumes, ugh.
John Hasse: Then I was, attempt.
John Hasse: and the University of Minnesota Art Gallery for a few months. Then I went off to graduate school at Indiana, and…
John Hasse: I chose that.
John Hasse: Primarily because David Baker was there.
John Hasse: Who has, by then.
John Hasse: The leading jazz educator, and over the years, he became… that reputation became more and Solid.
John Hasse: And…
John Hasse: The music school didn't seem, however, like a… very,
John Hasse: Appropriate or welcoming home for me, because
John Hasse: They only taught one course in world music.
John Hasse: No ethomusicology in the School of Music. One course in world music, and that was, of course, in…
John Hasse: The classical music of India.
John Hasse: Ragas and things like that.
John Hasse: So I enrolled in the folklore Department to pursue ethomusicology.
John Hasse: My professors included.
John Hasse: Alan P. Merriam.
John Hasse: the… Great ethnomusicologist who is in the anthropology department.
John Hasse: George List, Frank Gillis… Charles Boelais?
John Hasse: Ruth Stone, people like that, and then I…
John Hasse: Of course, I studied with Henry Glassie, Richard Dawson, And, and… folkloris, and, it was…
John Hasse: Really rigorous, because in order to get a PhD.
John Hasse: I had to take something like 5 qualifying exams. I had to master the entire field of folklore, and, separately, the field of vets and musicology. There's some overlap, but…
John Hasse: Mostly not a lot of overlap, and so it took,
John Hasse: I think probably took 2-3 years to get through my qualifying exams, and then, of course.
John Hasse: I spent at least a year on my dissertation.
John Hasse: And when I graduated, I had been named a Danforth Fellow.
John Hasse: For future college teachers.
John Hasse: But when I graduated, there didn't seem to be a job
John Hasse: For me, with my particular specialty, I wanted to teach the history of American music and jazz and…
John Hasse: Couldn't find a job, so… I enrolled, I applied to…
John Hasse: mini MBA programs at NYU and Wharton, and got into both. I went to Wharton.
John Hasse: I think there was an 8- or 10-week program. We get daily courses, and… Statistics, micro…
John Hasse: Economics, macroeconomics, finance, administration, marketing, And career development, and then…
John Hasse: corporations came to recruit the 30 of us, and I landed a job at my first choice, Procter & Gamble.
John Hasse: Doing marketing management on head and shoulders shampoo.
John Hasse: Learned a hell of a lot.
John Hasse: But I felt like a…
John Hasse: proverbial square peg in a round hole. I really didn't fit, and it kind of… the job quashed my creativity.
John Hasse: So… I was fired after 13 months, and…
John Hasse: struggled for a while to find a place. Then this job opened up at the Smithsonian, and I looked at it. It said, Curator, Division of Musical Instruments.
John Hasse: Specialist in 19th and 20th century vernacular American musics.
John Hasse: I kept looking at it.
John Hasse: And finally, just before the deadline, I called the head of the search committee.
John Hasse: I said, you know, I don't… I'm not a musical instrument expert.
John Hasse: We talked for a while, she said, you should apply. So I did, and…
John Hasse: I guess there was something like 50 other applicants, and…
John Hasse: after some time, they invited 3 of us to come to Washington for a day of
John Hasse: Talks and, interviews and…
John Hasse: I guess I just fooled him.
John Hasse: Fooled him for 33 years.
John Hasse: So, that was, that was… that became my dream job. I was…
John Hasse: I was like a kid in a candy store, I mean…
John Hasse: It drew on everything I'd done before.
John Hasse: from, field work?
John Hasse: To, marketing, to… writing… For scholarly audiences, writing for popular audiences, collecting… Archiving…
John Hasse: Speaking to the press, Things like that, and…
John Hasse: I did mention, but when I was at IU, I…
John Hasse: undertook a research project on the history of ragtime in Indiana and produced a 2… Record set with a…
John Hasse: Big 28-page booklet, and that one, that won an award.
John Hasse: And I also produced, recorded an album of my own ragtime piano playing.
John Hasse: So, I'd had experience… producing records, and that was useful at the Smithsonian as well.
Julie Stout: Do you think that you're, you mentioned you got to do marketing at the Smithsonian. Is that what led you trying to go to, like, the business school for a little bit, to see what else you could do, or what led you down to, like, for your MBA, that route?
John Hasse: Well,
John Hasse: I didn't want to be unemployed or one of those so-called gypsy scholars where you teach.
John Hasse: One course at one college, and another course at another college, and you're…
John Hasse: Driving between campuses all the time, and… Terrible pay, and no… no security,
John Hasse: So I… I'd done things that you could call marketing ever since I was a little kid.
John Hasse: Gone door-to-door, selling… subscriptions to TV Guide, I…
John Hasse: Popped peanuts and popcorn in the…
John Hasse: university basketball games. I'd started a little… Stamp collector's Club item.
John Hasse: Help market the… the jazz trio and the rock band that I was in, and…
John Hasse: Then, when I worked on this presidential campaign, that was… Until the candidate
John Hasse: It was Senator George McGovern from my home state of South Dakota.
John Hasse: Before he won the, nomination in Miami Beach, at the presidential convention.
John Hasse: I was in charge of the whole campaign in Minnesota. Once he got the nomination.
John Hasse: The campaign needed somebody more experienced, so they hired somebody with…
John Hasse: was older, with more political experience, but I was in charge of it.
John Hasse: communications, which was… campaign literature.
John Hasse: Advertising, an organized campaign of writing letters to the editor.
John Hasse: all that kind of stuff, and so I'd had…
John Hasse: Various kinds of experience that you could call marketing.
John Hasse: And so that… it seemed like a natural…
John Hasse: If I wasn't gonna be able to… teach, and…
John Hasse: I didn't see a future of myself as a…
John Hasse: Full-time musician, it was just too iffy.
John Hasse: It seemed like a… Logical.
John Hasse: Next step.
Julie Stout: Like, you maybe imagine there's, like, more stability there in some… in a, like, in…
Julie Stout: In terms of, like, because teaching seemed to be more ambiguous, in terms of, like, job prospects and everything.
John Hasse: Well, I… The fact is, I couldn't… I couldn't get a teaching job.
Julie Stout: Right.
John Hasse: one or two.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
John Hasse: Parents had been teachers, and…
Julie Stout: Right.
John Hasse: One of my… two of my sisters were teachers, and… My family revered education.
John Hasse: I got called out for one interview, it was at UCLA.
John Hasse: They wanted somebody not to do research, they wanted somebody to sort of babysit babysit a,
John Hasse: Class of 500 undergraduates, including… a lot of jocks, or athletes.
John Hasse: Survey of Jazz History class, and…
John Hasse: You know, they… without saying it, the university wanted
John Hasse: Them to pass, not fail this class, because
John Hasse: The athletic department would have really gotten upset if their Students had flunked.
John Hasse: So, it was a… It was a really,
John Hasse: Wasn't a good job, and it was…
John Hasse: The pay was $14,000 a year.
John Hasse: And that was less than the cost of housing in LA at that time, so it was…
John Hasse: That was the only… interview I had, and I tried lots of different places, so…
John Hasse: I won't say I was getting desperate, but I was getting, worried.
John Hasse: And so… when this job offer at Procter & Gamble came up, I… I jumped at it.
John Hasse: It was going to be, you know, intellectually challenging, Good salary, good benefits.
John Hasse: Interesting city, Cincinnati.
John Hasse: Has an interesting musical history.
John Hasse: But, it, it, it just… Wasn't right for me.
John Hasse: And although I looked at it at the time as a defeat.
John Hasse: Since then, I've realized that by firing me, they did me a favor.
John Hasse: Because… Rather than getting sucked up into the corporate world, It allowed me, eventually.
John Hasse: to find my way to the Smithsonian as an accidental curator, because I never planned to be a curator, and have this…
John Hasse: Career that was so, they're gratifying.
Julie Stout: What draws you to education? What draws you to teaching, the next generation?
John Hasse: I think teaching is one of the most noble professions.
John Hasse: Passing on knowledge.
John Hasse: You know, and… even…
John Hasse: If you're well up on the ladder, reaching down and pulling the next person up behind you.
John Hasse: Helping people Learn, fulfill their potential, succeed.
John Hasse: after all, children and young people are the future. I mean, that's such a corny thing to say, but…
John Hasse: That weighed a lot on my mind, and…
John Hasse: Just speaks to my core values.
Julie Stout: And leading from that into your creatorship, role at the Smithsonian, can you tell me a little bit more about that? Because I know you mentioned you were able to fit so many different, like, things into it, like marketing, like teaching, like, collecting.
John Hasse: Can you tell me more about that?
John Hasse: Yeah, the… Responsibilities of a Smithsonian curator we're…
John Hasse: Somewhat analogous to a university professor.
John Hasse: Both have to do research.
John Hasse: Both have to do teaching.
John Hasse: at the Smithsonian, We teach mostly through doing public exhibitions.
John Hasse: Rather than… Classrooms.
John Hasse: And… University professors always are expected to do service, university service of some sort.
John Hasse: We were expected to do museum service or public service, or both.
John Hasse: It was one area in which Most university professors aren't.
John Hasse: Obligated to pursue, but we were.
John Hasse: Fundraising.
John Hasse: Because Congress… gave the Smithsonian, or our museum.
John Hasse: the National Museum of American History, enough money to…
John Hasse: Turn on the lights, open the doors, you know.
John Hasse: protect the national collections, but that was about it. Anything we wanted to do beyond that…
John Hasse: Whether it was an exhibition, or a research project, or…
John Hasse: Recording project, or travel to a conference.
John Hasse: We were expected to raise the money That was a… Huge challenge, I…
John Hasse: ended up being quite good at it, but it was not something I really enjoyed. I hadn't gone to…
John Hasse: I hadn't spent all those years in graduate school to… To do fundraising, but,
John Hasse: It was part of the job, and… So I did it.
John Hasse: And, it was the only place I could have done
John Hasse: most of the things I ended up doing, for example, Leading…
John Hasse: the effort to acquire Duke Ellington's vast archives.
John Hasse: He left behind… about… 200,000 pages of documents.
John Hasse: half of that unpublished music that he composed for his band, the Duke Ellington Orchestra.
John Hasse: Probably couldn't have done that at a university.
John Hasse: Because we got,
John Hasse: We managed to get Congress interested, and they gave us an earmark of a half million dollars.
John Hasse: Toward acquiring and cataloging the collection.
John Hasse: first… jazz artifact I acquired was Dizzy Gillespie's Last Trumpet.
John Hasse: He was famous for having a…
John Hasse: A bent trumpet with an upturned bell like this.
John Hasse: And, Probably couldn't have acquired that if I'd been at a university. You know, it took a…
John Hasse: prestigious National Museum to persuade him
John Hasse: To donate it, and he came down, and we had a press event.
John Hasse: with, with 15… radio, TV, and print reporters, it was… The area was… error was… Crackled with electricity.
John Hasse: And then, a few years later.
John Hasse: I led our efforts to acquire Ella Fitzgerald's archives.
John Hasse: I was able to found a national jazz orchestra, the Smithsonian Jazz Masterworks Orchestra. Again, managed to
John Hasse: Well, we've managed to get some congressional funding to start that, and…
John Hasse: I turn first to David Baker of the Indiana University School of Music.
John Hasse: Who by then was a dear friend and mentor.
John Hasse: To become the… First musical director.
John Hasse: and… in… 2000… 2… I managed to start a national Jazz Month.
John Hasse: It's called Jazz Appreciation Month, or JAM for short.
John Hasse: And it's now… This is its 25th year, so it's silver anniversary.
John Hasse: It's celebrated in all 50 states and in dozens of other countries, and again, that would have been very difficult to do
John Hasse: At a university or college.
John Hasse: Because I was able to get support from the National Endowment for the Arts, National Endowment for the Humanities.
John Hasse: The Voice of America, State Department, U.S. Department of Education, NPR…
John Hasse: PBS, the American Library Association, all these organizations came together to form this
John Hasse: Loose-knit coalition of organizations all working
John Hasse: On a common cause, organizations that had never before worked together.
John Hasse: And again, That was possible.
John Hasse: In no small part, because
John Hasse: I was at the Smithsonian, so… I'm… So deeply grateful for her.
John Hasse: Having been there, and having… The opportunity to do these things and to learn so much.
Julie Stout: The, the idea that you were able to bring your visions to light and pursue these things that you cared about while also spreading, like, the word, and…
Julie Stout: Educating people that this is, like, something that even exists must have been, like, a gratifying thing, would you say?
John Hasse: Very much.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
John Hasse: You know, there were so many… gratifying experiences, and… Yeah.
John Hasse: moments that, I can't come… I can't come up with a strong enough, encompassing word to…
John Hasse: I mean…
John Hasse: There were many setbacks, and a lot of defeats, you know, worked for years to get a…
John Hasse: Collection of materials of Ellington's close collaborator, Billy Strayhorn.
John Hasse: In the end, after pursuing the family for 20-some years, they…
John Hasse: deposited the collection at the Library of Congress, and so all that work for all those years
John Hasse: Went down the drain.
John Hasse: That's just an example of, of… The defeats, and losses, but… And… Lots of weekends, and…
John Hasse: You know, nights, I even… Early in my tenure there, I…
John Hasse: Pulled some all-nighters at the museum, which…
John Hasse: The older curators were horrified about when they heard about it.
John Hasse: But overall, it was such a, it was such a high.
John Hasse: Emotional high of, of experiences that…
John Hasse: I sometimes have to pinch myself, Am I really here?
John Hasse: Herbie Hancock's house?
John Hasse: looking at his piano, I mean, really here at Quincy Jones' house, talking to him, and I mean…
John Hasse: You know, it was…
John Hasse: Am I really here in the South Lawn at the White House with the Smithsonian Jazz Orchestra?
John Hasse: at the second White House Jazz Festival of Asia.
Julie Stout: I think your face says it all. Like, I can… I can see it all over your face, your impression of it, and the fondness you hold towards it as well.
John Hasse: And deep gratitude.
Julie Stout: Yeah, and deep gratitude, yes.
Julie Stout: Do you have… did you have a favorite part of your job? It seems like…
Julie Stout: It… the way you were just talking, it made it sound like maybe seeing these things up close and personal really, like, sucked to you, but of course.
Julie Stout: I leave it to you to say.
John Hasse: Favorite part of the job?
John Hasse: Hmm.
John Hasse: I suppose it was…
John Hasse: I mean, it was fun to reach the people who were already
John Hasse: you know, hip to Ellington and… Coltrane, and…
John Hasse: Miles Davis, people like that, but…
John Hasse: The greatest kick, I think, was… exposing… Members of the public.
John Hasse: To something that they weren't already into.
John Hasse: Didn't know about. Didn't know that they liked.
John Hasse: In other words, bringing more people into… Into the subject.
John Hasse: And, I know this is jumping ahead, but… That's been…
John Hasse: the greatest thrill I've had since…
John Hasse: I started writing for the Wall Street Journal, in 2008.
John Hasse: today, I don't know, 60 or 70 articles.
John Hasse: All in music.
John Hasse: And… It feels like… musical missionary work.
John Hasse: You know, I'm not going door-to-door like some religious sex.
John Hasse: Do… trying to convert the unconverted, Follow that.
John Hasse: religion, but… I am… I mean, most of the people who read the Wall Street Journal or not.
John Hasse: Hardcore jazz fans, or… historians of American music, so… if I can… right… In a way that
John Hasse: Grabs them in the first sentence or paragraph.
John Hasse: Keeps them reading till the end.
John Hasse: And maybe they'll go out and…
John Hasse: buy some Ella Fitzgerald recordings, or…
John Hasse: Go check out our concert by… a fine musician.
John Hasse: That's the most… That's the most appealing thing for me, is to… enlarge the audience.
John Hasse: of curious…
Julie Stout: letting people know how great something is. Like, because you grew up with such a strong, like, music influences around you that it's natural that you want to be like, hey everyone, this is something that I find is really amazing, and I think you would enjoy it too. Here's more about it, basically. Yeah.
John Hasse: Yeah, and, you know, I'm so… every time the Wall Street Journal publishes me, I'm so…
Julie Stout: Yeah.
John Hasse: Because… I never expected To be writing for such a… prestigious publication.
John Hasse: I have no training as a journalist, none at all.
John Hasse: And I… I never considered myself, I still don't, as… A really good writer.
John Hasse: Rather, as a writer, Who values clarity, and…
John Hasse: Writes enthusiastically about.
John Hasse: things that… that I care about.
John Hasse: So I'm… It's something else that I'm bringing.
John Hasse: Grateful for, you know? Never expected it.
Julie Stout: Hey, as someone who doesn't know much about jazz, you're getting me excited about it in this interview, so that's something. Because your enthusiasm does show, it does show through.
Julie Stout: Can you remind me when you officially retired from the Smithsonian, and let me know what that was like for you, what your feelings were on that, and then I'd like to ask what you did after that.
John Hasse: June 30th, 2000, and… 16.
John Hasse: The… Museum put on a… retirement ceremony.
John Hasse: for me, and I was deeply honored that the… head of the Smithsonian.
John Hasse: He's called the Secretary. David Skorton.
John Hasse: Came and spoke, and so did Congressman…
John Hasse: John Conyers of Detroit, who was…
John Hasse: the leading advocate for jazz in all of Congress.
John Hasse: And I said I wasn't retiring, I'm rewiring. I was going into rewirement.
John Hasse: Because, I couldn't imagine just sitting around loafing in a hammock, or… Something like that, I…
John Hasse: Too many things I wanted to do.
John Hasse: It was really… it was a very tough decision, Julie, because I cared so deeply about…
John Hasse: what I was doing, and had so many
John Hasse: acquisitions I had… I've wanted to pursue.
John Hasse: And, you know, I'd spent years…
John Hasse: Building relationships with musicians and their families.
John Hasse: And this is… is such a, Cliche, but it's… Largely true that People don't give.
John Hasse: Money or other valuables to institutions.
John Hasse: They give it to other people.
John Hasse: So, what that means is you…
John Hasse: To build a relationship with somebody before you ask for
John Hasse: They're prized possessions, just like you wouldn't… a man wouldn't ask a woman to marry her on the first date.
John Hasse: You don't ask somebody to give you something that They hold near and dear.
John Hasse: on the first meeting, you… so it… It takes…
John Hasse: Sometimes it takes years and years and years to build these relationships, and… When you leave,
John Hasse: You have to leave most of these relationships behind.
John Hasse: And you don't know who's gonna come in
John Hasse: Who, if anyone, is going to be hired to continue the work that you did.
John Hasse: And the museum… Essentially loses the… The institutional knowledge of that Employee, The connections and the experiences.
John Hasse: It might be even more… of a loss.
John Hasse: Than it when a typical college
John Hasse: professor retires. It might be… might not be, but, you know, if… That the curator has.
John Hasse: Made all sorts of connections, and has… and if…
John Hasse: If she or he had another 5 or 10 years, could have brought a lot more…
John Hasse: Important and valuable material to the museum.
John Hasse: then… It's a loss for the museum, too, so it was… I think after… Almost 10 years, I'm still…
John Hasse: wrestling with that. It's… it's, I don't regret stepping down. I stepped down…
John Hasse: To spend more time with,
John Hasse: The woman I was just about to marry.
John Hasse: I'd been waiting all my life to find…
John Hasse: an amazing woman to marry, and I found her, and we got married in 2016, and…
John Hasse: It's been the greatest thing in my life.
Julie Stout: What is, your impression of the institution today? Do you still have contact with them? Because I know you said you're still kind of wrestling with
Julie Stout: You leaving, but you still wanted work… wanted to do some work?
Julie Stout: How are you dealing with that?
John Hasse: With the Smithsonian.
Julie Stout: Yes, yes.
John Hasse: Will they… as I went into rewirement.
John Hasse: they named me Curator Emeritus, which is a…
John Hasse: They consider a lifetime honor that
John Hasse: cannot be taken away, so I was…
John Hasse: I was very gratified when that happened, and… I still have,
John Hasse: some ties, I have an email, I've got a… A phone number, I've got an ID.
John Hasse: a staff ID?
John Hasse: And when I can, I help.
John Hasse: One or another curator with… You know, connecting with somebody who might be a donor.
John Hasse: I still feel very… loyal to the museum, and sometimes I'll say.
John Hasse: We, when I probably should say they.
John Hasse: But, it'll be part of, part of me.
John Hasse: to my last breath, I know.
John Hasse: It's, it's, it's a… It's a institution I…
John Hasse: deeply, deeply admire and revere. It's one of the…
John Hasse: Smithsonian is one of the world's great institutions, not that it's perfect, It's far from perfect.
John Hasse: It has its challenges and shortcomings, just as any other institution does, but… Its mission is so… Noble.
John Hasse: Its reach is global, its collections are staggering in number, and Variety and importance, and, as…
John Hasse: The director of the museum said, you know, not all the treasures are
John Hasse: in storage or on display, they're… walking around, I mean.
John Hasse: The curators there, so many of the curators have this.
John Hasse: Incredible amount of knowledge that
John Hasse: Including unique knowledge, unique to their research and their collections and things, and… So… It's an amazing,
John Hasse: It's an amazing group of,
Julie Stout: I… all I will say is that I echo your sentiments with what you just said, because this is your time.
Julie Stout: But,
Julie Stout: Do you have any anecdotes you'd like to share of your time there, yeah, that you'd like to share?
John Hasse: Whoa.
Julie Stout: Take your pick, I know it's a bit of a broad question.
John Hasse: Well… Desi Gillespie, agreed to… Back up.
John Hasse: I wanted to acquire Dizzy Gillespie's trumpet as…
John Hasse: the first jazz artifact that I was… to bring in.
John Hasse: And a colleague said, I wrote him a letter.
John Hasse: Days, weeks went by, months went by, no reply.
John Hasse: So a colleague said, Get Lorraine involved. Lorraine was his wife.
John Hasse: So I wrote essentially the same letter to her, and figured.
John Hasse: If Dizzy didn't respond, she probably wouldn't either.
John Hasse: Four days after I sent the letter.
John Hasse: to them in New Jersey, a great big box arrived, and in it was his last trumpet. I think she wanted it out of the house.
John Hasse: And after a couple months, he came down in person to, you know, present it formally, and
John Hasse: there were… the room, as I mentioned, crackled with electricity, and after an hour of regaling the…
John Hasse: Press and the staff with his wit and humor.
John Hasse: A tall British reporter, as if to summarize the whole press event.
John Hasse: stood up and said, Mr. Gillespie, 500 years from now.
John Hasse: What will that trumpet be saying?
John Hasse: Gillespie looked at him and said, 500 years from now?
John Hasse: That trumpet… Ain't gonna be saying nothin'.
John Hasse: The room exploded with laughter.
John Hasse: Of course, I had to silently disagree, because 500 years from now, it'll still be telling stories through the Smithsonian.
John Hasse: That's… that was one of my favorite anecdotes.
John Hasse: Indelible memories, like standing up, on a stage.
John Hasse: In Giza, Egypt, a few miles outside of Cairo, squinting into the sun, and introducing
John Hasse: The Smithsonian Jazz Masterworks Orchestra.
John Hasse: Conducted by David Baker's Indiana University's David Becker.
John Hasse: to the audience of Egyptians in front.
John Hasse: Behind me was the… the pyramids, The Sphinx?
John Hasse: Endless sand.
John Hasse: Just experiences like that, and it was… wow.
Julie Stout: So you were able to travel a lot, as well.
Julie Stout: Through… through specifically, like, that… the jazz orchestra, or like… Something else.
John Hasse: Well, to go meet with… Potential donors of stuff.
John Hasse: Sometimes to go to conferences, and
John Hasse: And then… but the Smithsonian didn't have A speakers bureau.
John Hasse: And I felt underutilized.
John Hasse: As a public speaker.
John Hasse: So… I, would go out, on my own time.
John Hasse: And give talks.
John Hasse: Sometimes, too.
John Hasse: town halls and libraries and museums about, say, Duke Ellington.
John Hasse: or to trade associations, places like the Cleveland Clinic and State Farm Insurance on…
John Hasse: topic of leadership, I developed a talk called Leadership Lessons from the Jazzmasters.
John Hasse: And, that was… That was… another unexpected thing, I never…
John Hasse: My life thought I'd be talking to the… Nuclear Regulatory Commission, or Cleveland Clinic, huh?
John Hasse: So that was a… That was a… emotionally rewarding.
John Hasse: pursuit that I followed for a number of years, and then… In the 1990s, I managed to get…
John Hasse: myself booked on the Delta Queen steamboat. It was plying the Mississippi River and its tributaries, along with his two sister steamboats, the American Queen.
John Hasse: And the… Let's see… Delta Queen, Mississippi Queen, and the American Queen.
John Hasse: And then I programmed a series of cruises for them on the theme, Music of the Rivers.
John Hasse: And, I recommended.
John Hasse: They hire, and they did.
John Hasse: Leading musicians like, The ragtime pianist Max Morath.
John Hasse: the, baritone… William Warfield, who was…
John Hasse: Concert artist who had also played.
John Hasse: In Porgy and Bess and Showboat on Broadway.
John Hasse: Hatberry Ramblers, the… singer-songwriter John Hartford.
John Hasse: And oh, those words.
John Hasse: We're seeing America at 3 miles per hour.
John Hasse: And, stopping at towns you never visit otherwise, like Paducah, Kentucky.
John Hasse: Or there happens to be a great museum of quilts.
John Hasse: or New Madrid, Missouri, which is a town that
John Hasse: There was a big earthquake there in… early 19th century.
John Hasse: so severe that the Mississippi Reversed course, and it rang.
John Hasse: church bells in Philadelphia.
John Hasse: You go to places that you would never go to, and…
John Hasse: You got to hear and talk with these wonderful musicians of various kinds.
John Hasse: So, that was another… bit of… Traveling that was,
John Hasse: Surprising, I never expected any of that either.
Julie Stout: So you guys go across the… not only the US, but the world as well, and, depending on if you're doing a conference, or more talking, or collecting, correct?
John Hasse: Yeah, and actually the… The international travel was mostly
John Hasse: Because the State Department got ahold of me in 2001,
John Hasse: They wanted to send a speaker to Spain.
John Hasse: to Madrid and Barcelona.
John Hasse: To talk about, Jazz.
John Hasse: I don't know why they picked me, but they did, and so…
John Hasse: I was there for about 4 days. It was… And that… Inaugurated a series of other
John Hasse: Trips that they sent me on,
John Hasse: Basically, the Smithsonian lent me for a few days.
John Hasse: And these were anything but junkets, because
John Hasse: You get there, you're completely jet-lagged, And you gotta…
John Hasse: Hit the ground running one time.
John Hasse: I had to be at a TV station at 6 AM.
John Hasse: This is in Nairobi, and they worked you all day and all evening long, and there really wasn't time to do sightseeing. It was just…
John Hasse: lecture, lecture, lecture, radio interview, press interview. But, hey, I was deeply honored to be representing our country and the Smithsonian, and…
John Hasse: ended up… Talking and… 8 African countries, and maybe… 5 in Europe.
John Hasse: And that was… that was an amazing set of experiences, too, so…
John Hasse: You know, I'm just a guy bursting with gratitude for all this. I really am.
Julie Stout: I think that is an amount of outreach I think a lot of people aspire to do, so I think it's really inspiring that you were actually able to do that and be a spokesperson for something you care so deeply about to begin with.
Julie Stout: So, I think that's amazing, yeah.
Julie Stout: So, taking into account the time after the Smithsonian, what are you up to today? I know you mentioned you're still writing, and you still are doing public speaking, but, if you want to talk more about that or other things.
Julie Stout: I'll leave that to you.
John Hasse: Well, I, I give talks.
John Hasse: Yeah.
John Hasse: During… two years ago, Ellington Centennial Year, I was…
John Hasse: I gave 3 talks at the University of Southern California.
John Hasse: 3 at Indiana University in Bloomington.
John Hasse: Peabody School of Music in Baltimore.
John Hasse: Town Hall of Denver, and that was… each of those was a kick.
John Hasse: And I've been speaking for, I guess, 6, 7 years to…
John Hasse: conservatory in Vienna, Austria, either in person or via Zoom.
John Hasse: And I've completed… a… A hybrid memoir.
John Hasse: It's a curatorial memoir of working at the Smithsonian, but it's also laced with some…
John Hasse: Musical, and particularly jazz history, and some cultural commentary on…
John Hasse: the history of museums, the Smithsonian's role, And,
John Hasse: It's, it's, it's seeking a publisher right now.
John Hasse: We'll see if it gets published.
Julie Stout: And that will reflect, like, your time at the Smithsonian and your experience, like, talking to different people about, like, their cultural expression and everything?
John Hasse: Yeah.
Julie Stout: Yes, exactly.
Julie Stout: Nice.
Julie Stout: I am curious about a day in the life of John Hassey.
Julie Stout: What does that look like for you?
John Hasse: Well, most of the day, I'm… I'm here at my… Computer.
John Hasse: Which is… Sitting before,
John Hasse: In front of two windows, so I get lots of…
John Hasse: light, which is always where I…
John Hasse: I do my best writing when there's…
John Hasse: Natural light coming in the window, and…
John Hasse: And my wife is a painter, an abstract artist.
John Hasse: So she's downstairs in her studio, and then…
John Hasse: We come together for dinner, and… Typically.
John Hasse: Find something really interesting to watch on television.
John Hasse: Then we have more time… time together on the weekends, and… I'm, very happy.
John Hasse: husband and, rewir-y.
Julie Stout: I, I liked your… oh, sorry.
John Hasse: No, go ahead.
Julie Stout: I was gonna say, you have a nice balance between, like, personal, and you're still working on things professionally as well, and I think that's…
Julie Stout: it's a blessing to have that balance, I think, as well, so…
John Hasse: I, yeah, I'm just, I'm just so grateful, and,
John Hasse: Sonya and I both say we've never been this happy, we never expected to.
Julie Stout: fine, so…
John Hasse: Who makes us this happy, and you know, we say, these… Are the good old days.
John Hasse: Because, you know, I've lost…
John Hasse: Two sibs, and 50 years ago, both parents, and…
John Hasse: You know, tomorrow isn't guaranteed for any of us, so…
John Hasse: These are golden days, and I'm… I just,
John Hasse: I try to keep that in mind, and… And, never…
John Hasse: Never be cocky, but just grateful.
Julie Stout: I think that, that sentiment resonates through our talk thus far, and a sort of wrap-up question I have for you is.
Julie Stout: If there's something you could tell your younger self.
Julie Stout: In any part of your life, what would you tell your younger self?
Julie Stout: Wow, that might be a loading question.
John Hasse: Oh, ashley… In the process of writing this memoir.
John Hasse: I wrote a letter to myself as a… just starting.
John Hasse: Curator.
John Hasse: I'm… Think more at about…
John Hasse: The advice was to my younger self.
John Hasse: Well… at one point, the… Museum director who hired me.
John Hasse: Roger Kennedy, this was in the… early 1990s.
John Hasse: He said, in a fatherly, way, not admonishing, but, just a little course correction. She said, Remember, John?
John Hasse: You're not a keeper.
John Hasse: You're an educator.
John Hasse: Because at that point, Some of us at the Smithsonian were…
John Hasse: Competing with some people at the Library of Congress.
John Hasse: For, our collection.
John Hasse: And it was getting… quite competitive.
John Hasse: And he… Wanted me to… Not be so possessive on behalf of the museum.
John Hasse: Stand back and realize the public doesn't
John Hasse: Really care what drawer it's in, or…
John Hasse: If it's in this building, or that building, or this, you know…
John Hasse: As long as it's safe and taken care of, that's what…
John Hasse: ultimately the public wants, and so that I should… Don't compete so hard.
John Hasse: And be more… cognizant of my role as an educator. I think that was good advice, and if…
John Hasse: Give that to a younger version of myself, I would…
Julie Stout: And, I guess, question tacked on to my last question, what advice would you give to students as well.
John Hasse: Who are maybe interested… yeah, today, who maybe are interested in…
Julie Stout: let's say…
Julie Stout: Cultural, like, studying cultural expression, curation, something along those lines, who are interested in going down that path of, like, outreach.
Julie Stout: And everything.
John Hasse: Hmm.
John Hasse: Well, this is not a high-level piece of advice, this is a very low-level piece of advice, but…
John Hasse: Always have a plan B.
John Hasse: And… Because, at least under the current White House.
John Hasse: at least under the current White House,
John Hasse: There's been a lot of upheaval in the cultural sector.
John Hasse: with cuts at the NEA, NEH, IMLS…
John Hasse: et cetera, the firing of the National Archivist, the firing of the Librarian of Congress, great pressure on the Smithsonian.
John Hasse: All coming from the President.
John Hasse: Particularly at this time, it's,
John Hasse: Can't necessarily count on Getting the kind of job that you… Dream of.
John Hasse: And so, it's… it's really good to have a
John Hasse: Secondary set of skills you can fall back on if you have to.
John Hasse: whether it's… 20 years ago, I would have said computer programming. These days, AI can do it.
John Hasse: But, you know, some other… Skill set that could, Lead to employment.
John Hasse: would be… A very practical piece of advice, Evan.
Julie Stout: I think that is very relevant for today, for not only the, like, humanities sector, even the tax sector is facing similar
Julie Stout: like, losses at this time, too, so I think that's very sound advice to give.
Julie Stout: Certainly.
John Hasse: Yeah.
John Hasse: Sharpen your mind.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
John Hasse: That's one of the advantages of a liberal arts education, because it makes you
John Hasse: teaches you how to think, I think.
John Hasse: Important thing is… Not so much the subject matter that you master, but
John Hasse: Sharpening your mental skills, your sense of curiosity.
John Hasse: Your sense of how things connect and don't connect, and… all those, grandeer.
John Hasse: things to.
Julie Stout: I could not say that better myself. On that note, we've gone through all of my questions, but is there anything you'd like to discuss or, talk about or, share?
John Hasse: No, I don't think so, Julie.
Julie Stout: No.
John Hasse: I have another appointment I have to keep, but this has been a lot of fun. You've asked some really good questions, and I've enjoyed this time.
John Hasse: Thank you. Thank you.
Julie Stout: Thank you very much! I'm gonna stop the recording.
Julie Stout: And…